the onyx logic introduction to
bioinformatics program
is an introduction to the field of
bioinformatics
or the intersection of informatics and
biology
in this program we will discuss the
changing landscape of data-driven
research and life sciences and the
opportunities that come
with the widely accessible high
throughput technologies
as well as computational methods for
analysis
and annotation of detailed data in
research and
industry we will discuss various data
types
emerging technologies as well as their
impact
on healthcare agriculture environmental
sciences
public health and more
in just six interactive sessions you
will get to see
the broad applications of next
generation sequencing
biostatistics as well as tools for big
data analysis
in practical assignments we will be
learning about the logic of
bioinformatics
to see how data science methods and
thinking can be used to study biology
in conclusion you will also be able to
plan how to take what you have learned
and apply it to an independent research
project using tools and methods
that we cover in the program preparing
biologists and clinicians for the influx
of data
associated methodologies and data-driven
research projects
is as prominent in biology as the
emergence of
computers for the tech industry more and
more biologists and clinicians are now
expected to both understand and handle
their own data
to publish and succeed in basic and
translational research projects
in fact biology itself is rapidly
acquiring the character of a data
science
billions of data points and genes
proteins and other molecules
are stored in large databases and should
be studied systematically
this program will give you a
comprehensive overview of bioinformatics
methods
and thinking for students biologists
and clinicians we will combine online
interactive sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience
that has proven to be so effective in
the well-known
and respected onyx logic bioinformatics
training programs
the coursework that you will have access
to will provide you
with introductory materials that have
been taken
by thousands of people from all over the
world
online quizzes will cover important
terminology and provide
a perspective from experts on this
exciting field
each course will provide you with
important information
and will allow you to see how much you
have learned
all of this activity is going to be
measured using our unique
point system that lets us identify any
technical issues
and resolve roadblocks that are so
common for bioinformatics starters
at the end of the program each student
will receive
a personal certificate of participation
you will also experience our novel
project based approach
to learning bioinformatics we take data
sets
from high impact publications and use
the methods described there
to practice the analysis these projects
include such topics as oncology
neuroscience agriculture
and many others as a result anyone
starting on this journey of
bioinformatics
can start developing a project of their
own
by seeing how experts analyze their data
and achieve research results
you too can start developing a research
question of your own
and identify the appropriate type of
data and plan
the analysis using tools and skills that
you have
gained for the duration of the program
we will be using
the t bioinfo platform to process big
data sets
this platform is built for multi-omics
integration
and analysis of structured data with
advanced methods like machine learning
and mathematical modeling this
analytical platform will provide a
hands-on experience for anyone
without any technical prerequisites they
can apply
the advanced skills to interesting data
sets with color-coded logical maps
explanation of methods detailed input
and output formats
and reproducible workflows downstream
analysis and visualization of process
data
can be performed in popular coding
languages like
r and python so we will also offer an
introduction to several basic methods
and popular packages used in
bioinformatics
from visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis
and hypothesis testing to machine
learning
this course provides a broad overview
but it is structured to offer
significant depth
even for the experienced user after
completing the short introduction
you will be inspired to continue
learning about this exciting field
of bioinformatics as a result you will
learn about
important bioinformatics concepts and
applications
various applications of next generation
sequencing
the role of data science for biologists
and
industry challenges addressed by big
data
informatics the program will be guided
by highly experienced mentors with
doctorate degrees
in bioinformatics and computational
biology
dr harpreet kaur will guide the
interactive
sessions offering advice and training
based on her
own personal experience that she gained
in multiple research projects
that leverage big data for exciting
discoveries
onyx logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between pine biotech
an innovative big data analytics company
based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omics
logic programs have been thoroughly
tested
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students
and faculty interested in bioinformatics
data science
and biomedical research after you
complete the program
we will also offer you to continue with
us
as a research fellow
to summarize we welcome you to join this
program
and earn a certificate of excellence for
advanced projects
or a certificate of participation for
basic training
anyone without any technical background
can join this course and learn about the
emerging field
of big data bioinformatics